et maintenant
il est
montanier
si west et véronique jannot
et
bonsoir c'est super il ya plein de
mauvaises soir l'émission démarre très
bien
1 alors en plus j'avais un bernard là ya
du lourd là ouais incroyable se
connaissent elles se touchent pas le
coût mais on a déjà travaillé
vous êtes au petit théâtre de paris deux
personnes de plus vrai oui alors vous
êtes donc chers véronique jannot au
petit théâtre de paris où vous reprenez
des fameux monologue du vagin à jamais
un moment de l'achat corrigeons donc à
la célèbre pièce de venture choisi est
ici lawson c'est comme ça qu'on dit et
c'est le seul bien aussi c'est
incroyable le nombre de comédiennes
qu'on joue et ses monologues du vagin et
fanny cottençon il ya sophie duez de
christine boisson firmine richard
princess erika claire nebout nicole
calfan lisette malidor vanessa demouy sa
force et ses mollets les femmes se
repassent comme ça la pièce et aux etats
unis aussi c'est une pièce qui tourne
dans le monde entier en fait c'est assez
joli oui il se trouve que c'est
important qu'elles existent comme ça à
travers le monde à ce qu'elles racontent
plein de choses essentielles essentiel à
c'est un texte qui était composée par
eve ensler à partir d'interviews de
femmes de tous âges de toutes conditions
et de tous les pays donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'eux c'est universel au
sujet de la femme autour du autour du
vagin laurent je suis désolé le mot
choque encore trente ans après re des
becs mais bon allons-y et faisant la
promo c'est trop côté [ __ ] non mais c'est
vrai que c'est ça qui vient laurent
l'origine du monde de courbet non mais
c'est vrai que trente ans après la
révolution sexuelle
on a on a du mal à parler du vagin oui
mais tout le monde est un peu un peu
gêné comme ça même vous bernard pendant
une grande gueule permanent ça ne pas
lui non l'avis médical
un bâtiment dé quoi alors on le dit
justement arrêté sous les noms qu'on
emploie pour arriver à la gratte tout
net services publics de l'amérique le
mot vagin est avancé 123 fo ne s'est pas
c'est page c'est pas joli non c'est vrai
que d'ailleurs on se dit dans la pièce
et nicole nicole croisille de l'écrit et
elle dit on peut le précédemment qu'on
peut prononcer de toutes les façons
qu'on veut il va jamais dire par contre
nous bénisse cet homme n'est pas
terrible non plus ses clés ni ouais je
suis de gynécologues donc jaoui qui ne
me choque pas du tout au pénis se trouve
ça très clean parce que ces éléments du
poney sont alors
gad et lancez-vous ressort alors environ
c'était épique et donc monologues du
vagin a créé en 1996 à new york
aujourd'hui jouer simultanément dans 30
pays donc c'est vraiment un truc assez
exceptionnel 1 la dernière présence sur
scène de notre amie véronique jannot
s'il ya longtemps et a longtemps c'était
dans pleins feux mais non c'était il ya
douze ans 191 la pièce de kalinka
absolument quand on regarde votre
carrière d'ailleurs on voit que vous
avez touché à tout mais sans vraiment
vous investira par la télévision
je m'investis en fait sur sur le sur le
moment j'ai pas de plan de carrière
n'hésite pas de plan qui n'ont plus
d'ansé les rencontres les opportunités
qui font les champs par exactement je
m'enthousiasme exactement votre vie
enfance dorée à la campagne oui vous
allez chercher du lait chaud à la ferme
votre jugement s'applique à vous
souvenez tout ça oui ah oui allez la
seule enfant très dalle en france et
puis vous êtes devenue comédienne
complètement par hasard puisque votre
mère envoyez votre photo à un annuaire
de cinéma un complètement comme ça et
cécile aubry est tombé sur ces photos
vous n'aviez même pas 15 ans et vous
êtes devenu la partenaire de son fils
dans le jeune fabre avec mehdi le fils
de cécile aubry mais déjà à l'époque
c'est marrant parce que vous êtes
toujours des plans b et vous les
toujours des plans de secours déjà les
pommes vous disiez si ça marche pas de
façon tant pis je suis forte en langue
et je fais autre chose
bah oui en anglais a plu aux défis du
théâtre vous avez fait l'école des
femmes
1 le rôle d'agnès à genève et puis vous
été rattrapé par les feuilletons télé
c'est à dire qu'en fait si on regarde
votre carrière
on s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois il était
rattrapé par la télé lui paul et
virginie aurélie et victorien voilà donc
la police le théâtre ça s'est arrêté
vous y revenez maintenant mais ça s'est
arrêté après l'expérience de long qui
vous choisit parmi 250 comédienne pour
former avec lui le nouveau couple du
cinéma français vous signez un contrat
avec lui alain delon d'y aller pour 15
ans voilà vous serez la star de demain
souvenirs on en apprend des choses c'est
vrai bien sûr celle émanant 3,6 et voilà
une douillette d'après lui la star de
demain mais le toubib sap a été un grand
succès le succès qu'il est ce qu'on fait
oui donc en fait on en a fait cas on en
a mais c'est pareil dans la chanson vous
avez fait la chanson avec voulzy qu'on
adore tous et après fini aussi à chaque
fois la télé vous rattrape par exemple
fait pause-café ça marche très bien fait
ça vous devenez jouer le mozart tout le
monde la connaît mais c'est vrai que
voilà la télé vous a toujours rattraper
mais les août carrière vous avez
abandonné assez rapidement et
l'impermanence c'est pas parce que vous
avez peur de dépendre d'une seule
activité non c'est sûr que c'est assez
déstabilisant pour prédire un petit peu
flippant fait de dépendre effectivement
d'une seule activité
c'est mieux quand on a plusieurs cordes
à son avis une façon de vous protéger en
fait c'est pas conscient mais il ya
sûrement quelque chose que je pense moi
j'ai ce pari avec les mecs vous avez
peur du département véronique mais c'est
vrai veronica peur de dépendre d'un seul
homme c'est vrai vous dit j'ai envie de
poser ma tête sur une épaule mais j'ai
peur aussi que les pôles se retire
brusquement c'est vrai mais oui j'appose
mais j'ai un petit peu en apesanteur
voilà toujours fait toujours peur que
l'homme s'en aillent et qu'ils vous
laissent tout seul pour vous poser
jamais vraiment la tête
non parce que mais parce que peut-être
les projets déposés j'ai été trahi donc
mais on est toutes pareilles way and on
vous laisse tomber la les autres
bon sinon non alors il ya qu une fois
vous allez poser votre tête sur une
épaule malheureusement c'était celle de
didier pironi ça s'est mal terminée
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui vous a un
petit peu guéri je dirais des aventures
à mais c'est pas c'est pas ça parce que
c'est pas un abandon c'est la vie qu'à
qui a décidé que mon travail puisqu'ils
étaient bonnes heures devait se
transformer en malheur mais donc c'est
pas ça qui mais j'aime pas trop parler
de de tout ça parce que c'est des cd des
moments des moments douloureux mais
c'est aussi des moments où je dis on
pleure toujours sur ce qu'on a ce qu'on
a aimé on pleure forcément montrer plus
fort parce que quand on a vécu très fort
quelque chose et c'est vrai que ce
serait dur et plus longtemps serait
sûrement été formidable et puis
peut-être que ça n'aurait pas été
formidable si ça va durer plus longtemps
on ne peut pas qu'on voit est ce que
c'est cette peur finalement de vous
poser je dirais qui fait que vous n'ayez
jamais eu d'enfant je dirais que c'est
la vie qui en a décidé comme ça ouais
ouais
quelques semaines avant que la suisse
est resté un enfant parce que le temps
commence à se voir
il suffit de vous regarder tant qu'on a
pas d'enfant on est un enfant et vous
êtes une femme en show et je crois que
c'est une femme enfant parce
qu'effectivement je n'ai jamais eu la
responsabilité d'avoir un enfant c'est
une réelle responsabilité de mettre au
monde un enfant surtout surtout
aujourd'hui je trouve aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que je devrais faire un enfant je
suis pas sûr que je serai choix d'en
faire un vous êtes pressé très juvénile
trop ouvert alors votre équilibre vous
l'avez trouvé cet extraordinaire dans le
bouddhisme et vous dites c'est assez je
vais m'expliquer ça je suis catholique
de conviction bouddhiste ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire que j'ai été élevé
dans la religion catholique j'ai fait ma
confirmation à première communion et
ouais mais que j'ai découvert
je dirais le bouddhisme en tout cas la
philosophie vous dise plus tard parce
que pour moi c'est une fille vous êtes
boulistes aussi parce qu'un homme est la
banque misr voilà c'est vrai on n'allait
pas avec la tâche à bout du bout du bout
de mon association est bel et bien sûr
et mais le foot de bouddhisme c'est une
philosophie ni avant et le dalaï lama
dit lui même pratiquer le bouddhisme en
plus
n'allez pas renier votre religion pour
ça c'est une leçon de tolérance
l'avantagent vous avez pas être obligé
de vous raser la tête vous au moins
parce que dernier parce que c'est un
engagement religieux coucher c'est quoi
le principe de base du bouddhisme aba'a
par les tongs c'est quoi on peut
vraiment faire quelque chose
d'extrêmement constructif et d'autant
plus constructif compte c'est d'abord
pour les autres c'est un choix de vie un
choix de à un vrai chemin de vie qui
croyez un ami j'étais vraiment une chose
qu bouddhiste
on revient quand je reviens dès samedi
prochain pour un bon nom crois que je ne
vous dis ça c'est au contraire c'est le
côté mais oui c'est compliqué c'est très
bon pour le temps là dans le coeur il a
alors c'est vrai que c'est vrai non
c'est vrai que cndd fera sortir de la
seule façon d'apporter la paix au monde
et d'apprendre soi-même à vivre en paix
bien sûr voilà c'est tout tennis ici
john lennon sentence alsace avant de la
faire dans la rue à désherber tous les
pays du monde donc on désarme pas
l'homme de toute façon toutes les
guerres continuent et surtout surtout
comme disait le poète et mon où vivent
vivons donc heureusement champ arrière
ce qui nous haïssent aimons nous les uns
les autres dans des boîtes échangistes
ces crabes à la bombe avarie pourquoi il
célèbre île c'est vrai pas finalement
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez commencé
par dire que c'est la tolérance
il ya des maisons hélas hélas hélas
hélas vous êtes en train de dire que ce
n'est pas possible de s'aimer les uns
les autres dans une maison où ils
s'échangent tout bois j'ai pas dit que
sur les changements
une odyssée charge il ya des bouddhistes
échanger sur leur nom sûrement il y en a
même je mange plus qu'ailleurs
alors est ce qu on a dit que j'étais né
à annecy oui je crois que monde s'en
branle mélenchon peut dire aussi sega ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
véronique a été élevé à seynod n'est ce
pas oui bien